STEVE, SEND IT BACK TO YOU.
STEVE: JILLIAN, THANK YOU.
FOX NEWS CAMERAS CAPTURED
EXCLUSIVE FOOTAGE AGAIN OF
DOZENS OF MIGRANTS LARGE GROUPS
WITH SOME CHILDREN CROSSING THE
RIO GRANDE INTO DEL RIO, TEXAS.
OFFICIALS INSIST THE BORDER
RIGHT THERE WHERE THOSE PEOPLE
ARE JUST WALKING ACROSS, THAT’S
NOT OPEN.
THAT’S CLOSED.
NOT KIDDING.
WATCH.
>> THE BORDER IS CLOSED.
WE ARE EXPELLING SINGLE ADULTS
AND FAMILIES UNDER THE TITLE 42
AUTHORITY THAT REST WITH THE
CENTER FOR DISEASE CONTROL.
WE DECIDED AS AN ADMINISTRATION
THAT WE WILL NOT EXPEL
UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN.
STEVE: WE KNEW THAT HERE WITH
REACTION THE MAYOR OF DEL RIO,
TEXAS, BRUNO DELZANO.
MAYOR, GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> I’M OKAY.
HOW ARE YOU?
STEVE: I’M OKAY.
THE SECRETARY RIGHT THERE SAID
THE BORDER IS CLOSED YET VERY
CLEARLY THE BORDER IS NOT
CLOSED.
YOU ARE ON THE OTHER SIDE.
IS THE BORDER CLOSED?
>> I WOULD VERY MUCH DISAGREE
WITH THAT STATEMENT.
THE WAY THAT IT’S BEEN HANDLING
OR BEING MANAGED IT SEEMS TO BE
WIDE OPEN FOR UNLAWFUL ENTRY
INTO THE UNITED STATES.
STEVE: OKAY.
YOU’VE GOT A PROBLEM BECAUSE A
LOT OF THOSE PEOPLE ARE COMING
INTO YOUR TOWN.
YOU’VE REACHED OUT TO THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR HELP AND WHAT
HAVE THEY TOLD YOU?
>> THEY KEEP TELLING US THAT THE
BORDER IS UNDER CONTROL AND I
SIMPLY DO NOT UNDERSTAND HOW
292% INCREASE.
RIGHT NOW AT 97 98 CAPTURES.
I SIMPLY DO NOT UNDERSTAND HOW
THAT IS UNDER CONTROL.
STEVE: NO KIDDING.
YOU HAVE BEEN DOWN IN DEL RIO
FOR AWHILE.  REMEMBER THE OLD
DAYS WHEN THE BORDER PATROL
WOULD BE ON ONE SIDE THE
AMERICAN SIDE OF THE BORDER
AROUND MIGRANTst WOULD BE
COMING OVER AND THEY WOULD GO
EH, STOP, TURN AROUND.
GO HOME.
IF A BORDER PATROL AGENT SAID
THAT THESE DAYS, THEY WOULD
PROBABLY GET FIRED BECAUSE THE
ADMINISTRATION CLEARLY WANTS
PEOPLE TO CROSS.
>> IT APPEARS THAT THERE IS A
DIFFERENT AFROZEN IMMIGRATION
EITHER WITH LOTS OF PERSON KNOW
ACTUALLY PATROL ON THE GROUND
AND I JUST -- YOU SEE THE VIDEO
52 PERSONS THAT VIDEO THAT WAS
SHOWN THE OTHER DAY IT IS
HAPPENING HERE IN MY COMMUNITY.
STEVE: SURE.
AND THE NUMBER ONE PRIORITY OF
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION FROM
THE GET-GO HAS BEEN COVID TRYING
TO GET THE TRANSMISSION RATES
DOWN AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT IT
EVERYDAY BECAUSE IT’S A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC.
HERE’S THE THING, AS THOSE
PEOPLE APPROACH THE UNITED
STATES, HOW MANY OF THOSE PEOPLE
ARE ACTUALLY BEING ALLOWED INTO
THE COUNTRY BUT ARE NOT BEING
TESTED FOR COVID?
THEY COULD BE BRINGING COVID IN
AND THAT’S ONE OF THE THINGS YOU
HAVE BEEN VERY CONCERNED WITH
AND YOU’VE ASKED THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR HELP AND WHAT
HAVE THEY TOLD YOU?
>> IT’S VERY PECULIAR BECAUSE
AMERICANS TO COME BACK INTO THIS
COUNTRY FROM FOREIGN
DESTINATIONS YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
NEGATIVE COVID-19 TEST WITHIN 72
HOURS PRIOR TO YOUR FLIGHT.
MEANWHILE, YOU HAVE PERSONS
ENTERING UNLAWFULLY THAT HAVE NO
COVID TESTING.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY WAS ADMINISTERING THOSE
TESTS BUT THEY HAVE RECENTLY
CALLED ME DR. EASTON RECENTLY
CALLED ME AND TOLD ME DH IS CAN
NO LONGER LEGALLY WILL ADD
MINISTER THOSE TESTS.
WE CAN CONTINUE THEIR TESTING ON
THEIR BEHALF.
I THINK THAT’S ABSOLUTELY
RIDICULOUS.
THERE IS OBVIOUSLY NO PLAN OF
ACTION.
IT’S BEING PAID FOR BY FEMA
WHICH IS OUR TAX DOLLARS FOR
NATURAL DISASTER.
AND I SIMPLY DO NOT UNDERSTAND
HOW ILLEGALLY CROSSING IS
CONSIDERED A NATURAL DISASTER.
MANY QUESTIONS.
FEW ANSWERS.
STEVE: NO KIDDING.
MAYOR, IT’S GOT TO HURT YOU HAVE
TO SAY THE ADMINISTRATION HAS NO
PLAN OF ACTION BECAUSE YOU’RE A
DEMOCRAT AND THIS IS A DEMOCRAT
PRESIDENT.
>> IT’S VERY DISTURBING THAT
THERE HAS CONTINUED TO BE JUST
EXTENSIONS OF FIXES WITH USING
BAND-AIDS.
YOU HAVE A BURST PIPE IN THE
MIDDLE OF YOUR KITCHEN AND
FLOODING NOT ONLY YOUR HOUSE BUT
THE ENTIRE NEIGHBORHOOD AND IT
APPEARS THAT THEY’RE USING DUCT
TAPE TO FIX IT YOU HAVE GOT TO
CUT THE SOURCE QUITE SIMPLY.
TURN OFF THE WATER.
STEVE: THAT IS SUCH A GOOD WAY
TO PUT IT MAYOR, THE DH IS HAD
THIS STATEMENT ALL ALONG THE
SOUTHWEST BORDER OUR TEAM HAS
ESTABLISHED PARTNERSHIPPED WITH
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
CITIES AND COUNTIES TO MAKE SURE
ALL MIGRANTS RELEASED FROM DHS
CUSTODY TESTED IN COMPLIANCE
WITH RECOMMENDATIONS.
WE HAVE A SYSTEM IN PLACE TO
REIMBURSE 100 PERCENT OF THE
COST PROVIDED THAT STATE OR
LOCALITY ACCEPTS THE FUNDING.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> I THINK THAT’S RIDICULOUS.
I THINK THAT’S ENTICING THE
MIGRANTS TO COME ILLEGALLY ALL
OVER AGAIN.
THEY WILL GET FREE TEST.
MEANWHILE AMERICANS HAVE TO PAY
FOR THAT TEST WHEN THEY’RE IN A
FOREIGN DESTINATION.
THIS DOESN’T MAKE ANY SENSE WHY
PEOPLE WHO CROSS UNLAWFULLY
ILLEGALLY GETTING THIS ROYAL
TREATMENT POST CROSSING.
STEVE: YEAH.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT?
SECRETARY MAYORKAS SHOULD CALL
YOU BECAUSE YOU SAY THAT
STATEMENT IS RIDICULOUS AND AT
THE SAME TIME YOU SAY THAT HIM
SAYING THE BORDER IS CLOSED.
THAT’S RIDICULOUS AS WELL.
YOU HAVE GOT A LOT OF QUESTIONS
BUT YOU HAVE NOT GOTTEN A LOT OF
ANSWERS.
AND THIS IS THE TROUBLING PART.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
STEVE: MAYOR, THANK YOU VERY